what
[Music]
and and there are many people who call it
a derogatory term, for example
they call it cholet the architecture kids
that sir for me this architecture
has its own language its own
identity its own essence
is a form of protest
we could also say it but to  through
architecture we are showing what we
are what we want what we liked and
what we have
my name is freddy mamani sylvester i am the
creator of andean architecture in
bolivia
i always liked to play and even as a
child with a neighborhood building small
citadels where i used to do  roads
building squares
buildings of mud and stone
I also come from the culture and the sea we
have not been taken into account the Aymaras
years ago before we were quite a few
emigrants crushed discriminated against
we were taken as second class
the Aymara culture has its own language
we have our own dance in  our
own music and now why not say
we have our  architecture itself
also
[Music]
comes from a fusion of two elements the
first element has been the
blood iconography of those geometric designs
that we see in the ruins
we use
bright colors bright colors
Bolivian cultures are not afraid
to show our colors
[Music]
this new  architecture is changing
the city from above
our avenues our gardens are
quite gray so we are
giving color to architecture and
we want to age the city ahead a little more in the future
because if you don't see your past you don't know
where you're going
[Music]